next example the Q Anon star Kirsten
Weldon who said only idiots get
vaccinated
is dead of covet
it's we're now getting multiple ones a
day
Kirsten Weldon told her fans not to get
vaccinated wanted Dr fauci killed she
believed he should be executed
she is dead of covet
a leading Q Anon promoter who urged both
her followers and strangers she passed
on the street not to get vaccinated died
Thursday of the virus
she amassed tens of thousands of
followers on right-wing media by
promoting the pro-trump Q Anon
conspiracy under the name Kirsten w
um Weldon focused on attacking vaccines
and other efforts to fight covid saying
in one video that Dr Anthony fauci needs
to be hung from a rope she claimed the
vaccine killed people and even recorded
herself yelling at people standing in
line to get vaccinated the vaccines
killed don't get it this is how gullible
these idiots are they're all getting the
vaccine
in December Weldon started showing
symptoms of the virus on December 28th
Weldon struggled through remarks about
the coming overthrow of the government
coughing and saying she was exhausted
three days later she found herself in a
hospital posted a picture wearing an
oxygen mask claiming she had bacterial
pneumonia she wrote she refused to take
coronavirus treatment remdessevier
calling it Dr fauci's resmedervir
misspelling it
this is the latest instance of a
far-right personality who opposed
vaccination killed by the virus I just
told you about Doug kuzma who also died
in the same way we've previously talked
about Robert David Steele
um we talked about Veronica walski A Q
Anon follower who was hospitalized with
the virus people started calling in
saying give her Ivermectin she died
later that month
um what is there to say at this point I
mean do we have sympathy my audience is
mixed on this I whenever I do a story
like this some of you write to me and
you say I have no sympathy they didn't
get vaccinated Etc
they are perpetrators they are also
victims
I mean there's if you fall for this
stuff in some way you are a victim of
disinformation it's it's a it's an
empirical reality you've fallen for
misinformation
you didn't create it you've fallen for
it and at the same time you are a
perpetrator because you encourage others
to do the same and who knows how many
people got sick as a result of either of
these individuals so I know my audience
is mixed on this
um but at this point in time
uh given the level of contagion of
Omicron and how easily it spreads the
vaccine is increasingly to protect
yourself with these individuals have
survived if they had had three doses
statistically it's likely
you you know you can't draw a conclusion
about an individual Doug kuzma with his
uh bronchial condition and the weight
he might have died either way we don't
know
statistically he would have had a
dramatically reduced shot at dying if he
had had three doses of course same same
with the with Kirsten Weldon here as
well
um so I continue to welcome your
thoughts about what should be our view
about things like this uh but get
yourselves vaccinated my my family lost
an additional person over the weekend my
uh my Dad's cousin in Argentina
um vaccinated initially down there they
had the Russian and Chinese vaccines I
don't know exactly which one he had but
vaccinated to some degree
um had pre-existing conditions came down
with the virus unclear where he got it
ended up being sedated on a ventilator
for three weeks developed infections
developed kidney issues horrible
horrible horrible devastating uh to the
family and he died over the weekend
um and uh if you have an opportunity to
get vaccinated take it because that's
the Fate afflicting
disproportionately unvaccinated people
my Dad's cousin had pre-existing
conditions there's no doubt about it but
he was not particularly old and it got
him why why not wear the suit of armor
if you're walking through the forest of
arrows why not wear the seat belt if
you're driving you might never need it
but you might uh and I I am convinced we
are going to see more and more stories
like this continue to come in